probably a weird time to bring this up  but i saw a [ __ ] ghost last night  where in my hotel room in the at the  bike i woke up at like probably five in  the morning and nikki's next to me i  roll over and i look up and there's just  a [ __ ] dude standing over our bed  what is he doing he's just standing  there staring down he was a shadow  though like this white lampshade behind  it was covered obstructed by him whoa  translucent in him no no translucent  [ __ ] it would look like some dudes  on our [ __ ] regular guy's stairs the  [ __ ] dude stayed in there over  ourselves  no not floating just standing there  staring down sit up he takes a step back  right [ __ ] off oh i'm not kidding so  he's closer to where the lampshade is  right i'm like [ __ ] confused i like  look over here and look back he's gone  wow  did you switch rooms no we're gonna talk  to them we'll see what if you get  charged for having an extra person  you look at it and